that new colin kaepernick
show
i think at some point you're just
creating content to
start real life
trouble
that's what i think i think
it just felt like pandering
to
race
race
racism that was just
it just felt like the lowest common
denominator for racial pandering
that's what it felt like
and it felt like it takes away from real
stuff that happens
or realer instances
um that's what it felt like to me now
i'm also a white guy
saying this
but
it just oh
it just felt sad
it just felt like you guys can do better
and you could put your face on something
better
you know
i'm a polish nicaraguan bad boy i don't
know ever you know i don't know anything
so but that [ __ ] felt [ __ ] cheap
um
kaepernick also in the news after
comparing being an nfl athlete to being
a slave he was slammed after this they
said
yeah that seemed like a lot a lot of
difference
a lot of difference
um
big difference
big difference been than being on the
49ers and being on the
zaire
slave
boat
i mean
that's you guys travel in a way
different class of travel that alone
a lot different
um
i think we all feel like slaves
sometimes colin when it comes to like
our jobs and stuff
but sometimes that's work
you could call it slavery if you want
you could also call it having a job and
why do they pick colin kaepernick for
this story couldn't you pick somebody
that's had a real real struggle
that i think that's something i do not
understand
pick somebody that's had a real str i
know friends that have struggled
way more than that guy
don't sell me struggle
with not a struggler
you better attach a struggler to
struggle daddy
or i'm not buying it so if you want to
sue netflix for anything carol baskin i
think at least throw that
on the radar
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one